our team recently received a screening
of the bumblebee movie and were happy to
say that the film takes a step in the
right direction to becoming the more
quintessential transformers story that
fans of the franchise will love opening
on the war for Cybertron
it's immediately apparent that the
previous aesthetic of the film has been
stripped away in favor of a more bright
and colorful tone gone on the darkly lit
bowels and hard to make out showdowns
replaced with eye-catching scenes and
neatly designed face offs those who
expect the CGI heavy affair know exactly
what they're in for
and bumblebee by far tops the series in
terms of special-effects cinematography
and character design this feels like the
80s cartoon brought to life in an
astounding way and is something fresh
and invigorating for the franchise
Charlie played by Hailee Steinfeld feels
like the perfect female counterpart to
Shia LaBeouf and she does well at
playing the enamoured eighties tomboy
that has been made famous by the likes
of stranger things et and it whilst
there are aspects that are slightly
derivative it's still engaging to see
this newest a and Hayley does a great
job she wonderfully restores the Beatle
car and it's refreshing to see the
Transformers take on something that
resembles a rust bucket rather than the
top-of-the-line sports model this herby
vibe definitely makes the characters
endearing early on and both adults and
children will find themselves
gravitating to the way that transformers
are reintroduced here Haley brings a lot
of fun to the film and I love seeing her
getting chased down by cop cars and she
genuinely seems like she's strapped in
for the ride and having fun with it John
Cena equally does a serviceable job as
an army soldier even though he doesn't
have as much screen time as you would
expect for the star this film isn't
going to blow you away plot wise and you
could probably guess the majority of the
movies moments from watching the trailer
alone however that doesn't mean that
this isn't an enjoyable journey for both
newcomers and hot core fans alike
overall this is a fun-filled kids movie
and there's a certain innocence to it
that was lacking in the original
Transformers films this writes a lot of
the wrongs from those movies in a
fantastic way and whilst is imperfect
it's very hard to ding the movie just
because
aspects are slightly predictable this
film is playing heavily on nostalgia so
if you like things like The Goonies ET
Honey I Shrunk the Kids and more you
will love it the movie restored a lot of
my faith in the franchise and really
feels like it's setting up some stellar
things to come down the line overall we
had fun with the movie and that's why it
scores a 7 out of 10 so are you excited
for the bumblebee movie and what you
hope to see in it comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and keep an eye out for my
everything explained video which will be
breaking down all of the major aspects
of the film this is a channel for people
who are mad into movies so if you want
to be kept up to date with all of the
latest news reviews previews breakdowns
and more hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]